[Music]
alright Sports starting to come back
thankfully to America and in the UFC
president Dana White intent on moving
forward with a May 30th event says he
will host it in Arizona quote a hundred
percent if Vegas cannot host it now
white recently just unloads on the New
York toilet paper times and a reporter
there for a misleading article joining
us now for reaction UFC president the
one and only Dana White you have no idea
how big a fan I am of USC the Octagon I
trained my own way but and I was glad
you ripped the New York Times how are
you gonna open up with a crowd god I
don't know how long that's gonna be it's
you know it's gonna depend on testing if
the level of testing keeps keeps going
up you know the president was talking
about a tab that you would lick and it
would tell you immediately whether you
had it or not I think it's going to take
something like that before we can bring
fans back you know you said something
the New York Times it was interesting
you said oh they haven't covered this
sport ever then they're attacking you
and then they get their clicks now
they're doing what two stories a week
and you told you kind of unloaded f this
guy I don't care what they think why
should you care by the way anyway well
first of all you know we were trying to
figure out solutions to the problems and
how do you bring sports back safely and
health and safety is an issue for us
every single weekend when we were
leading up to these events we had so
many you know New York Times has so many
other media people trying to sabotage
the events so that it it couldn't happen
I mean this guy this guy from the New
York Times interviewed the president of
ESPN Jimmy potaro for 45 minutes wasted
45 minutes of his time and never used
one of his quotes you know why because
they were positive yeah figures right I
think now they have these turnstiles
that you can walk through take people's
temperature I think that could be part
of it I would if I if it was a matter of
going to a UFC fight maybe even outside
right you can do that
in a lot of cities and if I had to wear
a mask for the safety of other people I
would I'd suck it up because this isn't
gonna last that long at some point this
all ends yeah it's it's crazy it's it's
tough to know you know you get different
information from from different people
and different sources you know we're
gonna end up living in a world where
you're gonna go to a sporting event
you're gonna have to sign a waiver to go
to a sporting event and you know and say
hey I know that you know the Cova
19 virus is out there and and you know
I'm gonna take the risk and go to the
sporting event I think I don't know if
temperatures you know some of these
states are or being absolutely crazy
about this thing I don't know if
temperatures is gonna work in every
state but if the testing keeps getting
better which it sounds like it is you
know we can have something where we can
find out right there at that moment if
you have copa90
well you can do that for everyone that
works all the fighters all the trainers
all the ticket takers that you can
definitely do all right so my staff
apparently sent you some of my my
training videos I've been doing this now
seven years and I do it four or five
days you're laughing that's not a good
sign if you're laughing at some of it
listen when I was growing up your
parents would put you in karate or
Taekwondo and that's the martial art
that people took this is the new martial
art that people are training in all over
the world I think it's great that you do
it it's one of the best things you could
do for yourself your wife your kids I
love it you know it by the way it's a
combination of Krav Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
Kempo boxing but a lot of Sai do a lot
of situational training obviously
there's some people Dana this may shock
you that hate me just in case protecting
myself
big fan
can't wait to go I'd love to one one of
these days go to a fight with you thank
you so much for being with us good luck
in your opening